hasta el momento no se conoce una
declaración del palacio de bukingham u
otro integrante de la familia real sobre
esta escandalosa entrevista del príncipe
harry y su esposa megan marcan pero es
tan delicado lo que afirman que
seguramente y se espera que lo hagan a
lo largo de este día en esta entrevista
que no ha sido vista la televisión
abierta del reino unido pero se hará
esta noche miguel marco asegura que
cuando estaba embarazada de su hijo
archi había preocupación dentro de la
monarquía sobre el color de piel de su
hijo dado que ella es la primera royal
de herencia afroamericana
megan también asegura que estaba tan
presionada y tan solitaria por el nuevo
cambio de vida en el que no podía ni
salir a la calle sola que pensó en
suicidarse cuando trató de buscar ayuda
profesional y preguntó así a la familia
real no se le permitió buscar esta ayuda
por su parte el príncipe de harvey
aseguró que su papá el príncipe carlos
el heredero al trono no le responde sus
llamadas
en varias oportunidades lo cierto es que
esta entrevista dará para un escándalo a
lo largo de esta semana y seguramente de
varias semanas porque afecta la imagen
de la familia real como una institución
más moderna